ist aufgabe leute probieren verkauft
ihren hund nie wirklich wirklich kassen
treffen und die wissen alles klar denn
jetzt kommen sagen die leute neues
format neue gast nehmen wir sitzt
verlieren und wir werden heute zusammen
eine runde auf mtv gehen und die werden
aber um tv wenn ich du wäre spieler muss
aufgaben vorbereitet und wir starten
direkt ein leute let's go es wird nur
noch eine sache sagen um
missverständnissen vorzubeugen verlieren
ist nicht meine freundin meine freundin
war mit dem raum dabei deswegen auf ihr
hund in dem video und jetzt viel spaß
ok erste aufgabe wenn ich du wäre wäre
ich richtig verzweifelt weil ich noch
nie ein freund habe und ich jetzt
dringend auf augenhöhe suche ich hab so
habt ihr schon so arme beziehungen ja ja
gar nicht mal ich weiß nicht ich hatte
noch nie beziehungsweise lost in tears
meine stimme sie zu stellen
das ist meine hatte ich vielleicht
welche tipps selbst sagen haben sollte
es nicht ankommen könnten die sache ist
die bei uns da wo wir wohnen nicht
richtig mein zweiter wahl in so eine
freundin hatte seine freundin sind voll
so dass hier der mädchen ich hatte
eigentlich keine frei so beschließt ein
bisschen austauschen ein freund und ich
letztlich geht sowieso am zweitmeisten
weil im jeder ab mittag in dieser
beziehung ist eine beziehung das
eigentlich so hätten also allein ich
habe keine ahnung hast du gesagt schon
mal zum schreiben sei also mit dir
selbst dann musst du halt gedrückt
du findest du nicht der richtige
200 da könnte was aber schon gut gemacht
und ich sagen okay dann mich ist
gespannt was ist deine aufgabe sehen was
sich alles vorstellen und zwar richtig
abgehoben so gefragt dass du kennst mich
kennt ihr nicht
wenn man diesen kanal also hoffen wir
hoffen einfach auf direkt sondern sagst
du kennst mich nicht eigentlichkeit mit
jäger das ist so krank oder in dem genau
solche leute hast du dich eigentlich im
netz ich hasse so leute die denken
wissen was besseres deswegen okay okay
was du findest du hast dich richtig
kelle und den ich glaube dass also ich
kenne deine youtube und bestimmt er
einfach nicht dass du möchtest du
glaubst und ich bin der erste bin ich
bin da hast du deppert er bekannt dass
youtuber deutschland eigentlich jeder
kenntnis in deutschland ja stimmen
eigentlich ich habe auch gehört dass du
für einen grammy nominiert wurde ist
oder premier ist doch musik ja ich mache
musik also ich sehe ab und zu unter der
dusche erfreut mich auf jeden fall ist
er nicht kennen weil wie gesagt
eigentlich so jeder kennt nicht also in
deutschland also genau eigentlich mit
einer der krassesten also ich sags nicht
so wie ich will auch bescheidenheit ist
weil sonst würde ich ja sagen ich bin
der kaste der welt was
endlich auch so ist also sec und hast du
musst dir überlegen ich bin auch
bescheiden wenn ich in die stadt dann
nehme ich halt doch nur den holzbau es
wissen
aber du musst jetzt spaß meint ernst so
also verlieren ich meine es aber auch
erstmals das modell mit dem jetzt aber
jetzt aber so scheiße als verhasste mit
du hast mich hier mal den eiern ist also
es gibt ja so viele user in deutschland
so kaum kraft da bitte und so aber
diesem level weißt du ob dieser
krankheit mein bruder mein zu ja ich
hatte den messen des nicht annähernd so
krass wie ich klasse daran ist kein hass
auf den so nah und deswegen weiß ich
weiß auch von jana warum die nicht mehr
zusammen sind so ich mit so einem
welcher nicht zusammen erst halte ich
das hat die sache so eben genau ich
glaube sie wollte immer dich ja ich
glaub ich finde aber gut dass wir auf
derselben wellenlänge sind also also das
ist die youtuber eigentlich auch der
galaxie die milchstraße ist ja ist ja zu
einfach
eigentlich geht doch über unsere galaxie
hinaus also die sache jetzt hätte ich
bin halt bescheiden weiß ich könnte auch
universum sagen aber man will auch
tiefstapeln so text abgehoben ich bin
noch immer korrekt wenn ich mir zb auto
zieren posten ist immer sofort auf
install damit die leute da wenigstens
ein bisschen daran teilhaben können wenn
sie schon nicht leisten können es ist
wohl selbst nicht glücklich ich bin von
mir aber ich bin mann des kriegs hat
diese frau braucht er etwas machen klar
wird dass machen natürlich für den
kassen würde ich das ja alles klar habe
ich für euch gefreut dass ich mit ihm
sprechen durfte
mach mal wieder das ist bei größe beruf
sonst würd sagen kann also ok alles der
eheleute jetzt wie es ist eben das game
ab jetzt geht's ans eingemachte
ich hol dir deine requisite 60 geschafft
sein
nein gehört sich auch und würdest du
wäre werde ich jetzt richtig besoffen
und wird so richtig leiden und so auf
ganze so antäuschen das unter vertrag
aber sieh zu dass es zu heiß dass wir da
hättest was wir keine werbung machen
[Musik]
genau das spürt dass jeder flasche
ausgetrunken solchen brücke jetzt nicht
rein
und der arme der habe ich bleibe so wie
es gut gemeint hast lange man eben rüber
als ob du hast also entweder du hast du
kannst ja zwischen den schein entweder
hast du schon mal bei den banken ja oder
du findest gebäude so hat sich auch
schon mal auf den finden so kann
entweder das oder um club fan club zu
hören nicht nur getanzt so hätte ich
nein
also ich wäre jetzt nicht sagen alter
ist eine klappe du bist du ich werde ich
für mich wissen will freundin natürlich
auch für die dabei dies verrückt hat
seine fressen bis 25 nein das ist gar
kein frage als bekannt voraus der
bankkaufmann haben uns die die zum
abfeiern
was ihr auch noch zum feiern ich war da
schon dass wir in köln
[Musik]
ich bin gerne da raus was er sagt also
war berlin köln weil ich dachte wird
irgendwie kommt ja so ein bisschen
gekannt haben sobald man kann meinen
vater in gang komme ich eigentlich immer
ganz gut an dass alle bisher sicher dass
wir noch nie getroffen haben hast du
lust hatte so einiges an die sonderschau
ich würde mich an jedes gesicht erinnern
was ich getroffen
der seit dem 1 800 nutzer aus dem
niederrhein
wie kann man sicher einschmuggeln
ausweis von der schwester oder von dem
mann der ähnlich aussieht welche tür
können na ja vielleicht auch einfach
gehabt aber dann soll ich mich dann
selbst wahrscheinlich jemand der so
ähnlich aussah
das aufgabe bestanden und ist das
schlecht ich finde es wirklich witzig
was sich da gerade dort alter kann man
dieses wort überhaupt über die lippen
bringt wie man sein image in einem video
zerstört zwei matches in einem video
leute ist aufgabe leute verlieren
verkauft ihren hund hören wir einen chip
die nach etwas mitmachen
das sucht dann einfach eine regierung
jemals einverständnis am arsch ich
verklage ich die opfer und die nada wird
jetzt verkaufst du hast dir sieben jahre
lang gehabt einfach kein bock mehr auf
die ganz klar so einfach dass ich für
deutschland mit einfach zuschicken also
dass ein bisschen wirkt so eine sache
ja ich kann ja auch schön
unterdessen versucht menschensprache
kurs camburg die das machen die menschen
mit dir ich hasse euch meine rache wird
grausam sein
oh mein gott leute ich hab so fett
abgeklemmt in diesem video aber machen
an dieser stelle jetzt mal ein deckel
drauf wäre ja noch einen zweiten teil
mit verwerten wollte dann schreibe es in
die kommentare auf jeden fall ist jetzt
auch als video bei ihrer online gegangen
ist der erste link oder beschreibungen
aus weil leute bis dahin macht gutes
auto